uh best piece of advice for someone 24
or a new millennial
out of college
ah boy i mean there's
it just depends so much on
your circumstances
um
i would say
you know just spend
spend more time
on making the big decisions uh there's
basically three really big decisions
that you make around that age it's where
you live
uh who you're with
and what you're doing right those are
the three big decisions and we spend so
much time in relationships you know an
average relationship probably lasts a
couple of years
but we spend very little time deciding
which relationship to get into we spend
so much time in a job but we spend so
little time deciding which job to get
into
choosing what city to live in can almost
completely determine the trajectory of
your life but we spend so little time
trying to figure out what city to live
in so if you're going to live in a city
for 10 years and if you're gonna be in a
job for five years and if you're gonna
be in a relationship for a decade you
should be spending one to two years
deciding on these things these are like
highly highly dominating uh decisions so
if you're 24
i would say those three decisions really
matter and you literally have to free up
your time because the world was will
assault you with its own agendas and you
have to say no to everything and free of
your time so you can solve the important
problems and those three are probably
the three biggest ones
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you